HubSpot allows all our teams to work
together seamlessly so no one's Fallen
overboard unless we want them to
[Music]
okay it's Sean and I'm here with one
question Friday where we take one
listener question and we play the audio
on air and then we try to answer we try
to drop a knowledge bomb right I'm
already imagining you listening to this
and your mind is your mind is blown the
brain is leaking out the air and that's
that's how you're gonna end this podcast
okay so let's go ahead and listen to
this Ben has sent me three audios I can
pick any one of the three haven't heard
it yet I'm going to pick door number one
let's go
hey guys my name is Matthew
and I have the question for Sean so he
talks about not wanting to be in the
imagination graveyard
what are some tips and tricks that you
do to keep your imagination creativity
alive
especially when you feel stuck or you
don't know what to do
oh okay perfect this is right up my
alley and let me break this down for you
in three parts I'll first start by
saying this
I think this question
touches on something a tactic that is
one of the most useful things that I do
that I don't really hear anybody else
talking about
okay so that's the that's the teaser
which is what I'm about to talk about is
one of the most useful things to me and
I rarely hear people talking about it so
let's break this into Parts you have
you're asking about imagination you have
this great little phrase imagination
graveyard I don't think I said that but
I'm stealing it from you so the first
thing is if I said all right picture
somebody who's got an amazing
imagination right who who in the world
has an amazing imagination often what
people think about is a child right so
when we're kids we get praise for our
imagination and we're always plant
making up games and stories and magical
creatures and imaginary friends and all
this good stuff so that's the first
place we go we think kids imagination is
for kids the other place we go is maybe
like a um I don't know like somebody who
works at Pixar like oh you're super
creative you create these movies or
stories so you need to be imaginative
and the rest of us we don't really need
that and um I think that's totally wrong
so I actually will put this forward I
think that everybody is using their
imagination every day but you just don't
recognize it because when you're a kid
your imagination is about fun and
possibilities and magical fantasy lands
and when you're an adult your
imagination is actually manifest as
stress right okay so what does that mean
um you wake up and you're you look the
alarm clock you see the time and
immediately you realize that oh man I'm
I'm gonna be stuck in traffic right so
where is your brain gone your brain has
imagined a situation that hasn't
happened that is not necessarily a fact
or proven uh but you're imagining that
the the either the roads are going to be
clogged or the airport's going to be
busy or they're going to lose my bag or
you imagine that oh I have this
presentation and I'm gonna I'm gonna f
it up right I'm gonna stumble on my
words or I'm gonna get nervous or people
aren't going to get it or people are
going to laugh at me whatever we are
constantly imagining
negative scenarios happening this is
very common in adults right and you know
how do you feel when you imagine these
things right you feel anxious you feel
stressed you feel depressed these are
all code words for the same thing fear
and fear only takes place in the
imagination
and so
um the first thing to recognize that
imagination is not just something that
kids do it's something that adults do
all the time they just code name it
stress and that's because they are
imagining bad scenarios that haven't
happened yet that might this happens as
a parent you watch your kid and instead
of being you know marveling at how
they're playing you're imagining oh they
might hit their head on that thing right
oh they might stub their toe over here
right how often do we do things like
that okay so that's step one now the
second thing is okay well what's the big
deal we're imagining this well what's
the implication what is the result of
this imagination well the first is how
you feel because when you imagine
something going poorly you feel stressed
anxious you know depressed sad whatever
whatever these negative emotions or
emotions that we usually don't want to
experience for an extended period of
time
so it changes our mood but it also
changes our decisions right if you
imagine that you're uh you're gonna be
stuck in traffic maybe you'll leave
earlier it'll take a different route or
maybe you won't go at all same thing
with you imagine that the presentation
is going to be you're going to forget
what you had to say and your the people
are going to be looking at you like you
don't know what you're talking about so
maybe you'll actually just ask somebody
else to do it or you'll avoid the
situation altogether so
imagination drives not just your mood
but your decisions
so what I mean if at the beginning of
this if I said how important is your
imagination you'd say yeah it's you know
it's important to have an imagination
but your mood and your decisions are
like the most two most important things
that you have in life and what I'm
telling you is that they're driven by
your imagination about what you're
Imagining the future to be like
and so um all of a sudden imagination
becomes this pretty important thing and
the problem is imagination is a muscle
that we haven't used consciously since
we were kids right like we're always
doing it in the background but how often
are we actually intentionally trying to
improve our imagination it is a muscle
that's just been weakening and
atrophying since we were like you know
five years old and um so here's how I do
it okay so that's the importance of it
now okay what do you actually do about
that well the way that most people in my
friend group my peers the way they think
is extremely rational analytical logical
and they love lists like nobody loves
lists like a business person and um a
doer an achiever they love lists right
you know write it down knock it off
and those do work to a certain extent
they actually work on getting a pretty
good result but they get there in the
sort of like toughest most stressful way
possible and I'm not really interested
in that right like I want to win and I
want to enjoy it while I go to me those
are two non-negotiable things not
willing to lose and not willing to have
this you know rough tough it out
experience
um I know I want to have an enjoyable
awesome experience while I'm doing it so
that's just the way I've chosen to live
my life okay so now
what I do differently instead of making
a list which is like a text format I use
the brain the way the brain actually
works which is a brain is more visual
system
and uh it's a visual auditory system and
so I use my brain when I think about
what I want to do my tasks my goals
stuff like that I don't make lists I
Make Scenes like scenes in a movie
so I'm imagining how I want something to
go and um I think I even started this
podcast saying something like that I
think I said I'm imagining you listening
to this with your mind blown and your
brain leaking right like I think I said
I literally said that at the beginning
of this podcast that is how I approach
anything so people are like you know
hey you do a lot of public speaking
um you know what's a tip to get better
and this is what I always say I say
don't think about what you need to say
first start by imagining the reaction at
the end how are people going to feel and
react at the end you imagine the
standing ovation you imagine I do this
for example I imagine when I teach my
class on Zoom this is like I teach a
course people pay a thousand dollars per
person to get into this course and they
show up in a zoom and I need to make
this thing lit it can't feel like a
boring meeting
I don't worry about what words I'm gonna
say I worry I think about how do I want
this to end how do I want this to feel
at the end here and what I always do is
I imagine the chat in a zoom chat
flooding with comments people being like
this was a 12 out of 10. oh my God so
many nuggets of gold dude so glad I came
um you know I'm imagining these almost
like congratulatory conversations that
are happening at the end I imagine the
volume of chat just flying through the
screen of positive feedback that gets me
in a certain type of mood right that
gives me that confidence that then I
could just go and I can just operate
naturally and the who knows the right
words just happen to come out of my
mouth then because I'm operating from
the right state of mind so what I'll do
is I'll Make Scenes for my goals so
instead of saying I want to lose 10
pounds I will imagine looking myself in
the mirror and seeing what I see right
I'll imagine the scene of looking at my
body or even better forget the body I
imagined that I just posted my before
and after on Twitter and I'm seeing the
replies flooded in right so I'm using my
own psychology to my advantage my
psychology wants to get a bunch of likes
and comments on social media so I use
that to my advantage I imagine that
scene going the way I want
um if it happens to be with finances or
success I imagine
you know a scene of that success so I
don't have to worry about how I get
there I just want to know what it feels
like when I'm already there and um so
here's some tips in doing this I have a
scene what I do is I have a scene for
all the different things that matter to
me in my life I have a scene for let's
say my family for example I don't really
share this with most people but I you
know family is super important to me and
um so I imagine this scene of me walking
into my house and you know like as a kid
you run up to your parent you like cling
onto their leg like a little koala so I
already imagined one kid on one leg one
other kid on the other leg and then one
kid koaling on my arm and then me
leaning over to kiss my wife right
that's the scene that implies a house
full of love right so that is I sort of
imagined the happy ending at the end and
that's my scene that I go to that puts
me in a certain mood that gives me
Clarity of what I want and then once I
have a great mood and great clarity of
what I want I tend to just make the
right decisions along the way right I'm
operating from a place of abundance
instead of a place of feeling like I'm
lacking something and then I make shitty
decisions because my you never want to
make decisions from Panic or fear or
feeling desperate or a lack because
you're going to make a certain type of
decision I want to make decisions from
feeling good feeling confident imagining
all the possibilities and I want to make
decisions that will lead me into that
into that outcome okay so I'll leave you
with a couple tips on if you actually
want to go do this take your goal that
you've written down instead imagine it
as a movie scene
like a like a movie scene it's not just
what you see it's what you hear it's
this it's all your senses try to use as
many of your senses as possible so what
do you hear what do you see how does it
smell how does it feel to be wearing
those clothes to be sitting in that car
to be sitting in that chair to be
sleeping in that bed right uh try to
engage all five senses it makes it more
Vivid for you the other thing is make it
comical right so a movie can be a horror
movie a drama movie I don't know for me
I choose comedy and so when I imagine
something I imagine almost the most
extreme version of that because it makes
me laugh it takes a lot of the weight
off my shoulders things feel really
important and tight when you are kind of
afraid of them but once you play with
the idea in your head you play with that
scene
um it becomes lightweight and then I
like to operate from a place of
something being lightweight
um and so that's how I do it that's how
I use my imagination
on really a daily basis and it becomes a
practice and I want to practice my
imagination more than I did as a kid
when I used to make up you know little
stories with my figurines and my toys or
you know when I used to draw and sketch
and do things like that I used to work
that muscle out a lot back then what I
realized is you got to do that as an
adult too because your imagination is
always running and it's just what is it
about what is it running on autopilot by
default it's kind of gonna imagine
stressful possible negative outcomes
that that tends to be where we go as
adults and I don't want to fall into
that path right that's common I'd like
to go uncommon and so the uncommon path
is to actually train that muscle
practice imagining things that you want
that puts you in the right mood and that
lets you make decisions from from a
place of um you know from a place of
winning rather than fear of losing all
right so that's it hope that answers
your question and uh I'll see you guys
next Friday
[Music]